remember our caller from the three four
seven area code who's calling today from
three four seven hello
David yeah that's you hey how's yan um
so I actually I used voted for Trump in
2016 but now I'm leaning towards more
about Bernie Sanders okay what's in it I
guess I just wanted to talk
Oh my name is Phil Phil okay and what
made you vote for Trump in 2016
Oh honestly I think I just fell victim
to a lot of the reactionary propaganda
that was just kind of going around and
like Facebook and YouTube
but like anti sgw sort of things and
that's so anti led you to vote for Trump
right and what made you what did you
think he would do for you on on the
basis of sjw's well I I I guess I have a
lot of conservative friends and our
group was like all about the you know
anti like sgw culture like the anti like
politically correct culture that sort of
thing and is it common that you just
kind of like do what your friends say
not anymore
okay it was at the time phone some sense
yeah yes yeah I was also on board with
there like I felt kind of like I wasn't
really on like the you know political
correctness culture that was going on I
felt like it was being a bit too
oppressive but it would be an example of
the nourisher learn you were worried
about well like i guess what we thought
was more prevalent was how people would
just get fired from you know saying
something that might not be seen as
politically correct and then they would
get called out for that and then lose
their job like i guess that would be
like an example of something like that
and what were some examples of people
that that happen to I honestly can't
give you specific example top bad right
now was good was there any specific
people you know I remember being aware
of at the time
like vaguely I can't really bring it up
right now
so you had generally heard people were
getting fired for things they said and
you didn't like that so you voted for
Trump in some sense fun fun yeah I guess
so well let me ask you this I want to
move on to how you ended up supporting
Bernie but were there particular people
on the internet that whose videos you
were watching that were influential in
in that sense so honestly not really I
actually used to watch destiny back in
like 2010 like I was a big star card
player and before that I kind of stopped
watching him from the periods 2014 maybe
like 2017 yeah and then I started
watching him again in 2017 he he
actually had like a completely different
change of you on his own politics okay
and I was like wait a second you know a
lot of what he's saying makes a lot more
sense now and it kind of started doing
my own research and I guess I'm more on
the progressive side now okay so now
your so but I think like yeah I don't I
didn't really watch any like you know
like the Ben Shapiro's or whatever that
I guess the Conservatives I listened no
okay
all right good all right so we've
established that so and then was there
is there a particular issue that has
pulled you over to Bernie as a bright
other people oh yeah so I'm an
environmental engineer and climate
change news I guess it's a really big
issue for me and as far as I can tell
Bernie's plan on climate change is the
most far-reaching expensive one from any
of the candidates what particularly do
you like well I like he infrastructure
change that's my opinion one of the
biggest things that should be done in
terms of climate change to meet climate
change is like an energy problem it's a
thermodynamics problem the way we
utilize energy to produce all aspects of
our society right arms so that needs to
be changed so his you know his whole
attack on fossil fuel so to me that's
just the right way to go
okay Wow listen that's a great but it's
shocking what you voted for Trump given
these are your views but I'm glad you
eventually came over listen listen
that's that's how I feel right now man I
yeah cool but I just had a specific
question so you know being that I want
the most progressive candidate to be the
Democratic nominee or say Bernie loses
in Iowa should odor shifter stance on
for example like Warren like listen
here's the thing I always gonna happen
New Hampshire's gonna happen
Nevada's gonna happen South Carolina's
gonna happen you nothing needs to if
Iowa doesn't go if you don't vote in
Iowa and Iowa doesn't go the way you
want but then it comes to New Hampshire
and you vote in New Hampshire vote the
way you want in New Hampshire it's only
for primaries and you're not gonna do
anything wrong you don't need to be
strategic if you vote in one of those
first four states just go for whoever
you want to vote for and then we'll sort
out the numbers later it's all gonna be
sorted out you don't need to start
changing a vote if Iowa doesn't go the
right way you know yeah that's kind of
how I was thinking about those issues
you were considering I wanted the most
progressive candidate to get the
nomination so I was gonna vote on
whoever kind of wins Iowa Budaj edge
wins Iowa then it's kind of a toss-up in
my view just because you know how long
state what stage a vote in fill where do
you vote I'm actually from Brooklyn so
you're voting in New York State yeah
okay so you've got plenty of time you
don't need to do anything and that my
sense is that this thing will be we will
be well into figuring out who is likely
to be the nominee by the time it gets to
you I don't think you're gonna have to
be considering voting for Pete Budaj
edge let me make that prediction right
right you're gonna do no I'm saying of
Buda judge Buda judge you're winning
Iowa might not actually be a bad thing
because he probably would pull from bite
and support that's kind of where I was
going with that
okay I'd have to look at the numbers
Phil listen I'm gonna move on and talk
to a couple other people I appreciate
you calling in and you are gonna get a
very very high score in our call system
because you did a great job of telling
us interesting thank you thank you
appreciate it
very good